you know it's funny I was thinking about
when I was a kid earlier today and I
want you all to kind of think about this
with me when you were a kid you were
probably doing things that your parents
said don't do this and don't do that
don't put your hand on that hot stove
did you always listen I know I didn't
and that's the thing sometimes we have
to learn things for ourselves we have to
understand how we make decisions for
ourselves because that's how we learn
things in our lives so touching that hot
stove remember that throughout this
fast-forward to today and one of the
things as Chris mentioned that we all
have to think about is all the
JavaScript things in the universe Sasha
had a great opening with the surveys to
show you all the different things that
are out there how do you keep up with
them we ask ourselves these questions
all the time how do you keep up with the
latest things how do you know what not
to be looking into where do you spend
your time out there how do you choose
the JavaScript framework for you and I
get asked this question a lot I imagine
you hear it a lot as well how do you
choose a JavaScript framework for you
well that makes it feel like there can o
be only one can there be only one of
anything that's out there at all times
maybe but let's flip the script a little
bit that's why I wanted to talk today
about this topic because it's something
I feel passionate about so when we talk
about our JavaScript frameworks we
should think about how we feel about
those frameworks because the tools that
we live in are the ones that make us
feel right they feel good they feel
productive so the question is not to ask
which one is best but which one feels
best to you hi I'm John Papa and maybe
we can figure this out together today
and how to choose your JavaScript
framework our choices weren't always
easy they weren't always good there were
times when there were about 50 of these
things out there any given week
literally at the tick of the clock there
might be something new on the internet
talking about a new framework that you
could use well today the good news is we
really can't lose there's a lot of good
choices and I'm going to narrow the
field down to the top three
sascha mentioned them
morning in the survey that you all gave
feedback on we can use react we can use
angular we can use view and how do we
look at these are these the questions we
ask ourselves what are the features
what's the community like what's the
documentation like how fast are they we
can ask those questions but when we do
it all starts with a simple question of
which one feels best to us we'd like to
sit there and think how do we choose
about them so where do we start and who
do we look to well first it's simple
let's look to the surveys and polls the
state of JavaScript is one of the great
ones that are out there and thank you
for Sasha and team for doing this for us
and we all answer these questions to
figure out what is everybody else doing
out there in the world first I wanted to
share with you one of my favorite
questions in the survey notice that most
of us feel like JavaScript has gotten
very complex but yet pretty much all of
us love it
so we like hard things I guess maybe
that's why we're in this industry but
it's interesting because then you look
at the question that he focused on there
about what would you use again or we
like to learn and easily react and view
or the top two in that list and angular
fell behind at 34% when you combine
those two stats so here clearly react
and view are the ones that people want
to learn or use according to the survey
well that must be it right well what
about the Stack Overflow survey a
different set of questions different set
of audience in some cases and this
question they asked is which tools do
you use today slightly different wording
and on this one notice that angular beat
out react on this one but what you don't
notice is there's no view view is not
even on this survey how can that be it's
all matter perspective and how you ask
questions and where they come from and
who actually answers those questions so
where else do we go do we go to the
24-hour Twitter polls that people like
me put out there we had 11,000 people
answer this one react beat out angular
and then view is behind it but you had
to be following me during the 24 hour
period that I put it out there and
happen to feel like answering the
question is that a great way to make
your decision upon your career
maybe so where do we go where does this
leave us the surveys have tremendous
value it is one data point that we have
to consider but there's other ways to
think about how we make this decision so
use that information but also our own
experiences have to go into this well I
talked about in beginning how we have
different features we want to look at
different questions in our analytical
minds always go to features so which
features are the best amongst these
frameworks and if we look at things like
components they're all based upon them
but they all handle them differently
performance which one is the fastest out
there state management how do they
handle that and what about lazy loading
itself so on component communication
let's take a quick look at the three and
react we use props to send data up and
down we also do that with view we can
send our data into components with props
in angular basically the same thing we
have something called inputs that we can
use to pass data down and the way we can
send data up one of the ways is to use
props with react with a view we can use
the emit command we can also use an
event emitter and angular but most
people use rxjs observables so there's
just different ways to solve the problem
and again it's how do you feel about
those what about lazy loading some of
the differences here they all have it
it's all easy which is great and react
you can laser their components same
thing in view and angular you actually
look as load sets of components with
something called an NG module you
basically group them together into like
a bucket and you can lazy load those so
it's a different approach but yet they
all have the same features again what
about the common language by default
most people using reactor using
JavaScript angular typescript and view
Babel with JavaScript now you might
think well you know I like typescript so
I'll go to angular oh I like JavaScript
to go to react well what's interesting
is typescript is now becoming very
popular in all three of these languages
in fact view is actually being rewritten
with with typescript
it doesn't mean you'll have to use
typescript to use it but the actual
language itself the framework itself is
being written in typescript and a lot of
people are starting to use typescript
and react as well so it gets a little
muddier there again
what about their standout features when
you think about react most people think
of components because everything is a
component and react I love Dan Abramov
every time we talk to what's a component
everything is a component and it really
is it's just a function that's what it's
known for if that appeals to you that's
great
with angular it's known as a full
framework that can be there good thing
or bad thing everything's there that you
need or it can feel bloated at times as
we heard earlier and with you we hear
about the simplicity everyone talks
about how easy it is to get going and to
build applications and to keep being
productive let's take a closer look at
one of the more popular features in all
three these state management which
became really popular with different
technologies one specifically with redux
with react and with reacts redox this is
effectively what you do you go and you
create your actions and your reducers
you create your api's to talk if you
want to have effects as well and all
your state is managed through redux you
might have code that looks something
like this in your application well can
we do that pattern and other
technologies we can use the Redux
pattern and view using view X and view X
effectively has the same things with a
couple slight differences although the
patterns change a little we're mostly we
create one file to manage the state's
reducers the mutations are actually in
view X instead of reducers and the
actions that are in there but we still
have the same things and then an angular
this something called ng rx an NG Rx is
the redox pattern in angular and
interestingly there's new library out
there called ng rx data which actually
makes writing the Redux pattern and
angular the least amount of code out of
all three but the point again being that
all them can do this in state management
is hard ok so maybe one of those appeals
to you well we get back down to features
and really you can build any app
successfully in any of these
technologies any of these frameworks so
where do we draw the line and where does
this leave us why is this so hard just
want to pick one right where you want to
go for dinner I don't know where do you
want to go
I don't know where do you want to go you
want to go that Italian place no how
about that Mexican place no how about
different no why is picking so hard
where does this leave us at the end of
the day so one thing I did is I started
emailing and asking a lot of my friends
and who are experts in different places
people like Brian holds and Ryan
Florence in the react world Sarah
Dresner and Chris Fritz from a view core
team Dan wylene from the angular folks
sir ask them why do you choose the one
that you choose what is it about it that
makes you want to use that tool and they
wrote back a lot of different things and
a lot of their answers vary across the
board I like because this feature that
feature that one but there was one
strong common thread how it makes them
feel they feel more productive I feel
like I can move faster with this one I
feel like the community is stronger here
I feel feel that was the common thread
that everybody talked about throughout
all of it how they feel about what they
choose so we end where we begin how do
you choose your frameworks my message to
you is to try all three of them try them
all if you know one it's not hard to get
into the others I use all three of these
myself and I'm varying degrees of
expertise of each of them and I build
different kinds of apps with them and
they appeal to me for different reasons
because of how they make me feel when
I'm coding and also very important be
okay with all three being good it does
not help our industry when we have to
have a winner when we have to say that
this one's bad or this one's bad and
this one's good having three strong
options is great because they help each
other move along out there when you
build three and here's an application
that I'll share with you put the links
at the end of this talk that I built
with all three and my goal was to show
how these three can look and feel under
the covers to build the
same kind of application on the surface
so the surface looks the same but the
way the code is laid out works more to
how these different frameworks actually
function under the covers
now you might code them so I did this to
try out how they looked and field doing
something other than it to do at and
first I start off with components and
there's various ways to do components
and react I could have used functions I
could have use classes I could have used
typescript could use flow lots of
different options I started with create
react app and I just stuck with
basically the defaults that they had
there because those are good defaults
and then I used a couple functions in
various places and then we can see the
component there on the left for that
with view I use a single file component
using the view CLI everything in one
place and then with angular I use the
angular CLI and I split the template
from the code because that's generally
by default what they do to see how all
the different worked and there were a
couple nuances throughout the components
based upon syntax or structure but
basically they were all the same so you
can check these out up on the links that
we'll share and here's how the
application looked I built application
with heroes and villains and the heroes
application protect cult or heroes here
it is for react and then here it is for
angular and then here it is for view all
three applications written from scratch
using those different technologies to
get a feel for how those applications
work so feel which one feels best to you
there must be one we all use something
out there maybe it's not one of these
three at all something different
entirely something coming down the road
but the way it feels best for you is
important for you to hold on to and to
understand it to really challenge your
own questions about how you asked about
these challenge yourself to stop
thinking about the technical and think
more about how it makes you feel when
you use these it'll also give you a
greater empathy for those who feel
differently about how they feel when
they use these Weiss and education
it's learned mostly through what you
discover on your own and not through
what other people like me tell you I
love this quote just like the burning
stove somebody can tell us which
framework is right to use use react use
view use felt use angular but yo Walmart
learned so much more by discovering it
on your own try it yourself here's the
links for the three of these and I'll
share these on the internet later today
or you can grab a screen shot all these
github repos will share the code you can
try to your own or try to build one from
scratch yourselves so which framework do
you choose that makes you feel the right
way for you think about that today which
one do I choose the answer might
surprise you but I'm not going to share
that today so thank you very much
[Applause]